et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
julien bayou bonjour enceintes
internationales d'europe écologie les
verts est candidat aux régionales en
ile-de-france on va en parler avec vous
bien sûr vous êtes avec nous pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale représenté par julien lécuyer
de la voix du nord on va parler dans
quelques instants de la loi climat mais
d'abord julien sur cette information du
matin le gouvernement qui annonce donc
l'abandon d'un quatrième terminal à
l'aéroport de roissy oui mais exactement
riano le quelle réaction vous apportez
donc à 7 cette annonce que du
gouvernement qui a demandé aéroports de
paris d'abandonner le projet de nouveau
terminal à roissy le fameux t4 car en
fait plus en adéquation avec les enjeux
environnementaux c'est plutôt une bonne
nouvelle c'est une très belle victoire
voilà c'est une victoire des écologistes
il ya eu beaucoup de mobilisation je
pense à la la coordinatrice qui a fait
de longues heures de garde à vue pour
dénoncer ce projet idiot en fait qu'ils
allaient augmenter les émissions de gaz
à effet de serre qui allait aussi généré
beaucoup de nuisances on en parle peu
mais l'aérien c'est aussi des nuisances
nocturnes
il ya un million de personnes dans les
couloirs aériens de roissy vers die la
barre dans le dans le val d'oise donc
oui il était temps d'arrêter pour le
climat et puis aussi c'est aussi une
question de bon sens avec la crise
sanitaire vous avez un effondrement du
trafic aérien qui va pas reprendre tout
de suite et donc ce terminal 4
il était absolument obsolète sur
l'aérien mais vous pouvez quand même
concédé que le gouvernement avance entre
l'abandon de notre dame des landes
la l'abandon du nouveau terminal t4 plus
les mesures qui sont on va en parler
dans le projet de loi climat et
résilience sur la réduction du trafic
aérien
on ne peut pas dire que le gouvernement
ne fasse pas de pas en avant pour
l'instant c'est des abandons voyez je
vois pas de pas positif c'est dire que
moi je me réjouis l'abandon de notre
dame des landes
il ya trois ans c'était une victoire des
écologistes 40 ans de mobilisation donc
c'est au gouvernement et dit oulala
c'est compliqué je ne le fais pas c'est
pas un gain positif
suivront des signaux importants en
faveur de l'écologie non en fait ce
serait le contraire qui serait
persévérer dans l'erreur voyez ce que je
veux dire c'est que dire aujourd'hui
avec le terminal 4 on va rajouter 500
avions
qui vont polluer et générer des
nuisances nocturnes personne n'en veut
donc en fait l'abandonner c'est le
minimum syndical j'ai envie de dire
s'ils voulaient nous attendons toujours
des gestes positifs notamment la réelle
suppression des lignes intérieures
quand vous avez une solution en train
pour trois ou quatre heures oui alors
dans leur nouvelle loi climat et
résilience le le seuil a été fixé à 2h30
sauf sauf si y'a pas toi y'a pas de y'a
pas de dire combien je crois il ya six
liaisons qui sont concernés je crois sur
wii mais voyez enfin c'est ça ça n'a pas
de sens a vraiment si on dit le kérosène
polluent et bien dans ce cas la taxe sur
le lay a pas d'avancée donc le diesel il
est taxé mais pas le kérosène en vous
fait on vous promet des interdictions de
l'intérieur mais le paris bordeaux alors
que vous avez un tgv qui fait ça en deux
heures il continuera de plus belle
vous avez une liaison masse et nice
monaco 6 minutes en hélicoptère
toutes les heures 600 euros donc c'est
100 euros la minute donc ça ça continue
alors vous pouviez y aller en bus pour
en 30 minutes
il ya un moment quand est-ce qu'on
retrouve un peu les pieds sur terre
c'est à dire que si on dit le
dérèglement climatique est une menace
pour notre santé pour même pour notre
démocratie vu les tensions que ça peut
générer sur l'eau sur l'alimentation
et bien en fait on met en face les actes
nécessaires alors ça se contenter voilà
il ya quand même des aujourd'hui il ya
quand même on va en parler avec julien
il ya quand même de nombreuses mesures
dans ce dans ce nom ce projet de loi
climat il ya des signaux quand même 50
de l'écologie et pourtant vous dit ce
texte
ils n'ont le trouve pas assez ambitieux
est ce que vous n'avez pas l'impression
d'en demander toujours plus non non non
c'est le gouvernement lui-même qui dans
l'exposé des motifs explique que ça ne
suffit pas pour atteindre les objectifs
qu'il s'est fixés moi j'y peux rien on
vous dit à une vague de cinq mètres qui
arrivent et le gouvernement et dit c'est
bon on va faire une digue de 2,2 m et on
est son simple dire c'est ça l'enjeu en
ville le l'effondrement menace la
biodiversité quitte la terre la vie
quitte la terre le dérèglement
climatiques génèrent ces différentes
pandémie non
donc parle depuis depuis un an
l'organisation mondiale de la santé nous
dit l'artificialisation des sols
l'élevage intensif la déforestation
vents provoqués de plus belle je
pourrais développer à foison leclerc n'a
frost libère du méthane qui va accélérer
le cycle du dérèglement climatique on a
des catastrophes de moins en moins
naturel des crues des inondations des
sécheresses l'accès à l'eau les
difficultés pour se nourrir et on nous
dit c'est bon on va on va faire on n'a
même pas la moyenne il faudra plus dire
non évidemment c'est une question santé
publique
voyez à ce niveau là alors maintenant
que vous avez mis une belle ambiance sur
ce plateau
après cet inventaire je viens quand même
des mesures qui vont quand même dans le
bon sens selon vous dont il y en a quand
même une cinquantaine de nouvelles
mesures et ce qu'il y en ait une
2 qui pourrait vous apparaître positive
bah écoute est vraiment alors aucune
dans le coup si je ne pas plomber
l'ambiance
l'artificialisation des sols n'ya pas
y'a pas une soutenons toujours la
mobilisation à gonesse c'est dans le
dans le val d'oise 300 hectares parmi
les les plus riches terres agricoles de
france il ya toujours un risque
d'artificialisation cette loi cette
mesure sur l'artificialisation donc le
fait de tout bétonner et fien ne
concerne pas les entrepôts amazon donc
en fait à un moment si on veut protéger
le petit commerce
eh bien on arrête amazon et donc c'est
gagnant pour le climat c'est gagnant
pour le petit commerce
si je veux arrêter de plomber l'ambiance
il ya tellement d'avenir tellement de de
désire aller chercher dans la transition
écologique et un stadium qui est pas
particulièrement une association
écologiste me dit il ya deux millions
d'emplois à aller chercher dans les
énergies renouvelables dans les
transports dans le vélo dans le tourisme
vert dans l'agriculture
deux millions d'emplois pourquoi est ce
que on va pas aller chercher les gens je
ne comprends pas cet attentisme par
exemple sur la rénovation thermique
on pourrait se chauffer correctement
économiser c'est l'équivalent d'un
treizième mois écolo finalement quand on
rénove votre appartement ou votre maison
les les la fédération française du
bâtiment je les avais récemment au
téléphone et larmes aux pieds 10 on
attend le carnet de commandes est rien
avancions je comprends pas cette entité
diarra votre place en recevait françois
de rugy cyril anciens membres de votre
parti il est maintenant député la
république en marche de loire atlantique
amis de la transition écologique et
regardez ce qu'il dit de vos positions
ce qui compte c est ce qu on traite les
problèmes c'est pas les symboles
je vois bien que un certain nombre de
nos opposants et notamment europe
ecologie les verts ils vont s'agiter sur
des symboles vous dira mais telle mesure
elle n'est pas exactement ce que la
convention citoyenne a prévu europe
ecologie les verts qui étaient contre la
convention citoyenne quand nous l'avons
créé du jeu c'est une manoeuvre pour
perdre du temps et puis maintenant qui
dit attention ce qui a été proposé par
la convention citoyenne doit y être
strictement mis en oeuvre dans la loire
bon c'est tout ça c'est de l'agitation
qu'est ce que voulait répondre définir
miles et c'est un mensonge puisque nous
avons salué l'initiative démocratique
que représente la convention citoyenne
pour le climat d'ailleurs il ya un livre
de grégoire frati et qui est un des
membres
un des 150 membres qui raconte un peu ce
set cette expérience qui qui précise que
europe écologie verts nous l'associatif
sur le sur les lacets mesurer bruit plus
que vous voulez le problème c'est que ça
ne débouche pas voyez la ligne cette
idée belle d'ailleurs c'est assez
intéressant vous mettez 150 personnes
dont des sceptiques dont des
abstentionnistes dont des gens de droite
et une très grande majorité de nos
écologistes vous les informer de manière
impartiale sur les conséquences du
dérèglement climatique
au bout de quelques mois il vous
produisent un vrai plan cohérent de
lutte contre le dérèglement climatique
on appelle ça le bon sens écolo plus de
plus de trains moins d'avions moins de
publicité mouvement de révolte était
finalement mais je crois que c'est
complémentaire
je crois que c'est complémentaire
aujourd'hui je vais pas vous apprendre
que le parlement fonctionne mal moi
j'aimerais que les députés puissent
voter selon leur conscience
aujourd'hui on a beaucoup de députés
dont notamment ceux de la majorité qui
ont été élus non pas pour leur parcours
mais parce qu'il avait l'étiquette lr
eux mêmes au bon moment et qui
aujourd'hui sont un peu prisonnier de
des desiderata du gouvernement
malheureusement et je passe
véritablement son rôle de contre-pouvoir
le sénat plus mais l'assemblée n'ont
malheureusement cela dit il y aura un
long débat qu'on pronostique comme un
débat aussi entre l'écologie de
contraintes et l'écologie incitative
vous sentez de quel côté vous moi je
suis écologiste
quand je vous dis il y a quatre cent
mille emplois aller chercher sur la
rénovation thermique uniquement sur la
rénovation des bâtiments publics 1 c'est
l'économiste gaël giraud je sais pas si
ces deux contraintes ou incitatives je
sais que c'est l'écologie c'est à dire
que vous luttez contre le dérèglement
climatique vous soulager le
porte-monnaie des françaises et des
français vaut créer l'emploi local non
délocalisables puis l'emploi qui a du
sens et vous lutter aussi contre les
particules fines parce que le chauffage
les bâtiments et mais des particules
fines qui en gros on sait génère des
maladies cardiovasculaires des
bronchiolites l'asthme enfin c'est
gagnant gagnant gagnant gagnant pour
qu'est ce qu'on attend
je comprends pas il ya aussi une
peut-être un décalage parce que c'est
vrai que beaucoup d'associations de
l'eau de l'environnement dénoncent le
projet de loi mais il est pourtant jugé
ambitieux par 63% des français et 75%
des des jeunes selon un sondage ifop
vous n'avez pas l'impression d'être en
décalage avec l'opinion publique je
crois pas à côté je vous dise à l'exposé
des motifs qui expliquent que le projet
de loi est pas suffisant pour atteindre
les objectifs que le gouvernement
lui-même s'est fixé mais lier à
d'ailleurs la justice et qui la justice
moins 40% d'ici d'ici 2016 c'est hélas
ce que disait barbara pompier dit y est
elle moins 40 cm - 40 % par rapport aux
émissions de gaz à effet de serre le co2
mais d'autres aussi la zone tout le
méthane des émissions de 1990 ça c'était
le plan
fixé à la convention citoyenne pour le
climat qu'a proposé 146 mesure ça veut
dire que si vous voulez rire 9 646 il ya
une fine et si vous les avez pas tout
et bien vous pouvez pas atteindre
l'objectif donc entre celles qui sont
amoindris celles qui sont passés à la
trappe et celles qui sont donc vous n'y
croyez le gouvernement n'atteindra
jamais selon vous les -40% est
d'ailleurs la justice c'est la justice
grâce à la sphère du siècle la justice a
constaté et condamné l'état pour
inaction climatique une carence
donc ils ont dit bah écoutez vous avez
pris des engagements ces engagements
vous oblige et vous ne respectez pas et
la justice le constate ça c'est une
avancée juridique majeure bien obligé
pour l'instant ça va venir
un dernier mot sur ce sujet avant de
parler de la crise sanitaire sur le
référendum promis par emmanuel macron là
vous y croyez vous pensez qu'il aura
lieu écoutez ça dépend beaucoup du sénat
pour notre part pour nous les
écologistes c'est une victoire
culturelle énorme que pouvoir envisager
le fait que le règlement intérieur de
notre maison le cadre constitutionnel
qui régit nos lois incorpore la
protection du climat ça évidemment
depuis le temps qu'on le propose
moi je me réjouis je pense à tous ces
éclats gyan de l'environnement existait
ce qui a besoin d'en rajouter
mais oui parce qu'il s'agit et c'est
donc là tout l'enjeu c'est la
formulation
il s'agit de garantir cette protection
aujourd'hui la charte de l'environnement
elle est insuffisamment considérées par
le conseil constitutionnel
elle est annexée à la constitution elle
est intégrée au bloc de
constitutionnalité mais par exemple
elle prévoit le principe de précaution
qui est bafoué tous les jours principe
de précaution vis-à-vis des
néonicotinoïdes par exemple donc si on
dit la protection du climat et la
biodiversité elle est garantie dans ce
cas là vous pouvez pas avoir d'effet
retour en arrière
le couvent le bilan du gouvernement pour
le sait la réintroduction de pesticides
dont on sait qu'ils sont dangereux pour
l'environnement et la santé
c'est ça l'enjeu mais on est en train de
préparer finalement un nouveau
chlordécone ou un nouveau scandale de
l'amiante sciemment voiliers et donc il
ya un an je veux vraiment de regarder la
réalité en face et pieds sur terre et de
faire le virage la bifurcation pour
notre santé pour les emplois pour le
climat on va parler de la crise
sanitaire les chiffres actuels nous
incite à maintenir notre ligne c'est en
gros le message délivré par le
gouvernement des chiffres qui sont
plutôt stables même si le plateau est
élevé est ce que vous dites que pour le
moment le gouvernement gère bien
cette crise sanitaire mais c'est
compliqué parce que j'ai pas tous les
chiffres dont dispose le gouvernement on
est assailli d'information évidemment
des experts qui peuvent se contredire
donc moi je m'en tiens à une méthode
nous avons besoin de concertation et
notamment les élus parce que les mères
avec qui je discute me dise pas écouté
on a peu d'informations
quand on arrive à voir le préfet qui
jouent le jeu
ils n'ont pas beaucoup plus et donc
d'abord et surtout un enjeu de
concertation et puis d'anticipation nous
disons depuis le début des transports
supplémentaires aux heures de pointe
dédoubler les classes là où c'est
possible pour embaucher les agents qui
permettent d'avoir des protocoles
sanitaires exigeant tout ça n'est pas
fait depuis un an je le regrette mais il
s'agit pas pour nous de leur ajouter la
crise à la craie oui votre actualité
aujourd'hui c'est le déplacement du
président de la république a à nantes
sur le thème de l'égalité des chances
il devrait y annoncer l'ouverture a pour
15 % d'aidés et des concours de cinq
écoles de la grande fonction publique
lena notamment à des élèves issus des
quartiers prioritaires de la ville
est ce que c'est pour vous une un
premier pas pour réparer cet ascenseur
social en panne
c'est un premier pas je crois que c'est
l'expérience qui a été menée à sciences
po paris fonctionne plutôt bien
j'ai eu l'occasion de rencontrer des
étudiants qui sont arrive à sciences po
par par cette voie ils sont ils sont
très heureux
voilà j'ai plutôt des bons retours ça
reste assez parcellaire s'ils voulaient
dans le grand projet de loi
[Musique]
visant à conforter les principes
républicains enfin je crois qu'ils vont
changer de séparatisme il ya un grand
manque un grand trou puisqu'il avait
dénoncé le fait que certains quartiers
joue le rôle de guetteur ou quoi une
ségrégation sociale c'est le plan borloo
moi je ne comprends pas pour en avoir
discuté avec avec borloo avec l'ancien
ministre qu'on n'applique pas son plan
un plan qui vous dit là-dessus jean
louis borloo parce que le gouvernement
et nadia elle nous l'a redit à quelques
jours dit que le plan bordeaux est
appliquée à 85%
elle peut dire ça sans sourire c'est ce
qu'a dit non cotées non il y avait des
enjeux d'investissement il y avait ce
projet des marianne de la république et
maison des femmes
jean louis borloo en éthique nom vous
dit que celui là il a le sentiment que
recommande de l'invité et il est il oui
il faut être lui sinon ce plan il a été
passé à la trappe alors qu'il y avait eu
un travail phénoménal pour le coup c'est
pas mon allié politique un jean louis
borloo mais les différents maires de
différents quartiers populaires de
gauche comme de droite salué la
concertation et ce plan qui pouvait me
sortir de l'ornière qu'est ce qui excède
l'emploi c'est créer l'emploi
je comprends pas pourquoi cet
investissement public il est dilapidé en
des milliards sans contrepartie
depuis maintenant qu'on a inventé le cic
eux depuis 2002 puis 2015
c'est 120 milliards d'euros 11,1
distribués sans contrepartie et là on
vous dit on va pouvoir faire de la
rénovation thermique on va pouvoir
moderniser des quartiers des
infrastructures de transports publics
désenclaver des secteurs entiers rénover
les écoles qui ça crée l'emploi pour
pour nos pme alors ce deal donc vous
parliez du projet c'est de l'eau au
séparatisme ce qui n'est pas illogique
non plus de sortir le logement l'égalité
des chances de manière générale de ceux
de ce projet de loi pour éviter d'en
faire une sorte de 2,2
deux projets de loi tentaculaire c'est
pas forcément idiot que de faire des
choses à côté et de valoriser comme par
exemple le 1er mai le premier ministre
certaines mesures pour le logement à
grigny là ici à nantes des illusions
pour l'agent logements fin je veux dire
logements pour les lois de
renouvellement urbain à paris ont déjà
les actuels aujourd'hui vous avez
beaucoup de lois donc on pense je pense
pas la cour des comptes a quand même
remis largement en cause la politique de
la ville en disant que les 10 milliards
condé qui sont investis chaque année
finalement n'ont pas réussi les
objectifs qui étaient fixés
moi je parlais la loi sru donc les 25 %
de logements sociaux quand une commune
ne respectent pas la loi dit déjà que le
préfet pourra intervenir c'est à dire
construire sur budget la commune le
maire veut pas donc vous mettez des
amendes et puis au bout d'un moment vous
constater l'obstruction du maire et donc
le préfet peut d'ores et déjà dire ok on
va faire ce programme de logements
sociaux et ça sera imputée sur votre
budget
t'as jamais été mis en oeuvre loyer est
pas forcément une question de budget ou
de nouvelles lois mais d'appliquer les
actuels l'encadrement des loyers
c'est bien emmanuel macron qui l'a rendu
facultatif aujourd'hui on sait que ça
fonctionne que ça permet à tout d'éviter
cette inflation des loyers qui qui rend
le logement insupportable c'est ce sont
des dépenses contraintes qui vous
prennent à la gorge l'énergie le
logement de transport un mot sur la
proportionnelle jeux wii comme le
rassemblement national où le modem vous
avez écrit à emmanuel macron pourrait
réclamer la proportionnelle aux
prochaines législatives
mais est ce que comme d'ailleurs le
souligne olivier faure le patron du ps
il n'y a pas un risque de d'ivoire quand
même un tripatouillage à un an de
l'échéance
ben c'est pas un tripatouillage c'est
une promesse du candidat macro donc à un
moment aussi on lui demande tout
simplement avec françois bayrou
on demande aux mêmes et l'arménie avant
on est un nom avant les gens que c'est
pour ça que nous proposons une loi qui
est possible de faire voter avant
c'était également une promesse du
candidat hollande il est écrit de cette
proposition de loi oui elle est assez
facile à écrire on peut reprendre
patrick mignola 2009
985 qui a été mise en en oeuvre en 1986
et il ne semble pas que le pays se
soient effondrés au contraire on est
revenu dessus les initiatives de 1986
elle était quand même un peu
particulière elle répondait à des enjeux
totalement politiciens pour le coup et
bien nous l'enjeu pour les écologies
même c'est la juste représentation des
des suffrages aujourd'hui quand vous
allez aux élections législatives
contrairement aux régionales par exemple
ou aux élections européennes et bien
vous pouvez voter pour une force qui
finalement sera pas représenté du tout
vous pouvez voir par exemple les
écologistes peuvent faire des scores 5
10 15 % aux élections législatives et ne
pas avoir de député c'est notre cas nous
n'avons pas député ou est-ce que vous
enfin j'ai fait un plaidoyer rien ne
vous empêche de vous allier à des forces
qui seront présentées à l'assemblée
j'ai fait un plaidoyer pro domo
évidemment mais est ce que vous trouvez
cohérent que aujourd'hui les écologistes
n'est pas de député à l'assemblée et je
vais même dire je combats l'extrême
droite et marine le pen et je trouve pas
normal qui n'est pas de groupe
voyez c'est une force qui peut faire
beaucoup trop un deux voies selon moi
mais il n'empêche un tiers un tiers à la
présidentielle et ne pas être en mesure
d'avoir un groupe à l'assemblée en
problèmes démocratiques 986 et de la
proportionnelle avait permis à plusieurs
dizaines de députés du rassemblement
national d'entrée vous essaierez à jouer
et c'est une manière de les combattre
mais grandes institutions et on nous dit
beaucoup d'éléments sur l'instabilité
je rappelle quand même que nos voisins
les allemands sont à la proportionnelle
intégrale et que anglais la merkel
chancelière a connu quatre présidents
auxelles qui pourrait parler d'
instabilité chez nous en fait cet
argument et ne tient pas la route et on
termine en parlant des régionales ah oui
grands dossiers aussi un vous êtes
candidats et candidats avec benoît hamon
ancien socialiste numéro 2 sur votre sur
votre liste
c'est un exemple de rassemblement qu'il
faudrait faire pour la présidentielle
par exemple moi je suis candidat tête de
liste pour les écologistes en ile de
france donc c'est vrai que je vais avoir
tendance à vous parler des régionales
les transports l'environnement
l'alimentation la rénovation thermique
le développement économique
j'entends que beaucoup veulent se
projeter d'emblée sur les
présidentielles mais ne nous trompons
pas d'élections voilà pour les élections
régionales et pour celle de la région
aujourd'hui le bilan de valérie pécresse
c'est la moitié des gens veulent quitter
la région
voyez donc c'est une région refus soir
trop cher trop pollué trop stressante
donc il ya un enjeu de prendre un virage
pour en faire une région où il fait bon
vivre et notamment
moi j'aimerais mettre en place des
indicateurs de bonne santé il ya
beaucoup trop de personnes qui souffrent
ou qui meurent de la pollution est un
indicateur sur les emplois créés ou
maintenus ces fameux emplois verts mais
juste sur la présence de benoît hamon
est ce que le rassemblement à gauche
pour vous il va s'arrêter là où il va
s'élargir encore l'enjeu c'est de
pouvoir se rassembler sur un projet et
nous on a dit c'est l'écologie la
locomotive c'est assez je suis dit mais
il faut des hommes derrière le mexique
c'est moi non seulement c'est ce que je
dis mais c'est ce que je fais et hier
pour moi c'était vraiment je vous dit en
fait c'est assez émouvant parce que bien
sûr il est benoît hamon illégalement
corinne lepage voiliers et donc deux
anciens ministres de génération vraiment
différentes de parcours absolument
différent qui d'ailleurs ont dû
passablement se chamailler dans le passé
et qui disent aujourd'hui il ya une
urgence ali climatique elle est sociale
et on salit parce que le projet la
locomotive c'est l'écologie
voilà je crois que c'est ça qui doit
aller on avait appris que c'était
derrière le projet mais est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui il ya des discussions
entre vous audrey pulvar et clémentine
autain bas on échange
très cordialement et chacun et des
discussions a cure des nuances mais non
pourquoi donc vous partirez à 3 trois
listes de gauche je sais pas en tout cas
il y aura une liste écologiste que je
mène et qui a l'ambition de transformer
la région créer ces emplois verts et
faire de cette région un endroit où il
fait bon vivre
voyez par exemple hier il ya eu cette
panne sur le rer b dont six aux heures
de pointe
elle lui disons investissons dans les
transports du quotidien plutôt que ce
projet de terminal 4 ou de charles de
gaulle express qui d'ailleurs emprunté
les voies de secours du rer b est bien
privilégiant les transports du quotidien
voilà un projet très clair très concret
c'est bon pour le climat c'est bon pour
l'emploi c'est bon pour le confort et la
vie la vie des gens voilà le projet
qu'on va mener une dernière question des
désunions pour
rassembleuse avec avec les socialistes
ça peut ça peut se produire ailleurs je
pense évidemment à la région des hauts
de france
les discussions en cours c'est karima
delli pour nous la tête de liste qui est
présidente de la commission transports
au parlement européen qui est très
active qui déplore d'ailleurs que dans
ce projet de loi convention citoyenne
pour le climat il est pas les
investissements dans le rail dans le
train qui nous avait été promis et elle
est oui elle est en discussion avec
différentes forces
tout l'enjeu encore une fois c'est le
projet
mais si vous trouvez un projet comment
est ce que vous pourriez vous effacez
derrière patrick hannais ou fabien
roussel puisque ce sont les candidats à
gauche je veux pas donner non mais c'est
pas les plus écologistes qui soit on va
dire de dire clairement ce n'est pas
possible nous le web le mandat que nous
avons donné c'est conduire une liste aux
régionales le mandat national syrien
il ya une vraie autonomie chez nous des
régions devant 10 poursuit vers un
projet écologiste et si vous trouvez des
accords et bien dans ce cas là c'est
l'orgasme quoi la question qu'on pose
c'est de savoir si vous pouvez imaginer
que karima delli ne soit pas en tête
mais nous sommes les seuls à l'avoir
nous sommes les seuls à avoir fait à la
présidentielle et à que notre parti qui
a retiré une candidature parce que nos
idées avaient triomphé chez le voisin
j'en connais pas d'autres en auvergne
rhône-alpes fabienne grébert il n'est
pas adhérent d'europe écologie l'air nul
ne met en doute le fait qu'elle soit
écologiste c'est tout ce qui compte pour
nous merci beaucoup merci julien veille
aussi à vous d'être noir regarde la une
de la voix du nord avoir 20 ans au temps
du coc vide
c'est à la une de la voisine or c'est à
la lune et s'est pas sentie blessée
parce que je voulais dit on va en parler
justement dans le club d'état est un
tout petit
la mutuelle nationale territoriale
la mutuelle des agents des services
publics locaux
vous présente le club des territoires
angie acteurs engagés dans la transition
zéro carbone des régions vous présente
le club des territoires
[Musique]
la presse quotidienne régionale et les
télévisions locales vous présente le
club des territoires et avec non pour ce
club vont nous rejoindre maintien de
sirop du figaro et jefferson et sports
de sud-ouest bonjour à vous merci d'être
avec nous on va parler avec vous du
malaise de la jeunesse en ces temps de
covile emmanuel macron est un nom pour
par l'égalité des chances et en
débattent sur le malaise étudiants
avaient lieu hier au sénat on va revenir
sur le mea culpa d'ours ou la vente de
rayonne la présidente de la commission
européenne qui était hier devant le
parlement européen elle dit avoir
sous-estimé les capacités de production
des vaccins
et puis on parlera du débat très attendu
ce soit entre gérald darmanin et marine
le pen débat qui aura lieu sur france 2
on suivra bien sur l'actualité dans nos
régions sera du côté de mme annie avec
guilhem brickaville le directeur des
rédactions de la provence mais d'abord
on commence par notre reportage à votre
rencontre on passe la semaine en haute
savoie est aujourd'hui direction
les stations de ski elle représente 40 %
le et vacances de février représentent
40% de leur chiffre d'affaires et en
haute-savoie ces stations sont
particulièrement touchés par la
fermeture des remontées mécaniques une
situation désormais critique notamment
pour les communes on regarde
[Musique]